today's video is about a princess whose
name translates to beauty in French she
is none other than Belle from Disney's
Beauty and the Beast we bet you didn't
know that Belle's very own mother read
her one specific book when she was
growing up be sure to watch until the
very end because we'll be revealing all
the details that help she fell into the
princess she is today
if you know anything about Belle and her
fairy tale then you know that this
princess loved books Beauty and the
Beast starts off with a sweet and catchy
song called Belle in this song Belle
sings about her own little town and how
everybody is the same here's a little
fun fact for you guys everybody in this
town wears all sorts of colors with the
exception of the color blue Belle and
the Beast on the other hand are always
seen in their staple blue outfits we're
guessing that Disney used this color to
symbolize just how different Belle and
the Beast are from other people in this
story another thing we noticed is that
throughout this song Belle repeatedly
mentions her love for books this shows
us that she could definitely be using
them to escape the world around her at
one point in her story she walks by a
bakery and tells the Monsoor about a
book she'd just finished reading the
book is about a beanstalk and an ogre
but just to be clear this isn't the book
that we're going to be focusing on in
this video still it's nice to know that
Belle is a fan of the classics when
Belle arrives at the book shop she goes
ahead and asks the librarian if she can
borrow a book that she's already checked
out twice before now pay close attention
guys because this is where the details
really matter
Belle tells the bookshop owner that this
book is about daring swordfights
far-off places she then things about her
favorite part of the book which is when
the princess meets Prince Charming
they'll goes on to mention that the
princess doesn't discover that it's him
until the very end of chapter 3 this is
the very book that we'll be focusing on
in this video there have been tons of
questions and rumors on what this
mysterious fairy tale could be well some
signs point to Aladdin while others
point to Sleeping Beauty and we're about
to tell you why signs that point to
Aladdin for starters we can definitely
check off the part about far-off places
daring sword fights and magic spells
Ruba totally counts as a far-off place
and we don't have a shortage of
swordfights either in regards to magic
genie in the magic carpet would
definitely count as magical creatures to
give you guys a little recap on the
prince in disguise
Aladdin once asked the genie to grant
him a wish in order to win over Princess
Jasmine with his lavish lifestyle and
all of his riches signs that point to
Sleeping Beauty as for the idea that
Belle is reading the Sleeping Beauty
book there's also a ton of clues as to
why this is also a pretty solid theory
we've got the far-off place down pat
since this classic takes place once upon
a time in a land far far away we also
definitely see a sword fight take place
between Prince Phillip and Maleficent
this story pretty much revolves around
magic spells as well
from the wicked spell placed on Aurora
to all the magic that the three fairies
flora fauna and Merryweather bring to
the tables
finally our prince in disguise makes an
appearance as Prince Phillip dancing
with Aurora in the middle of the woods
she in fact does not discover that it's
him until the very end of this story
we guess now there is nothing left to do
but to compare these two storylines do
you guys think that the book that Belle
is so interested in is Aladdin
or do you think it could be Sleeping
Beauty for Aladdin we're going to need
you to come in a red heart down below
with the hashtag Aladdin for Sleeping
Beauty go ahead and leave a blue heart
so for those of you who voted for
Sleeping Beauty this totally makes sense
since we do get a glimpse into the page
that Belle is reading oddly the picture
we see looks like something straight out
of Sleeping Beauty we see a forest and a
great castle in the background which we
have to admit looks nothing like Agrabah
on the other hand Disney is known for
hinting at movies to come and they do
this by releasing Easter eggs in their
newest films this could definitely be
the case with these two movies since
Aladdin was released just a year after
Beauty and the bees there's also the
fact that Princess Jasmine doesn't
actually realize that it's Aladdin
dressed as Prince ollie until later on
in the story maybe even somewhere near
chapter 3 so with both of these theories
looking pretty solid right now and a ton
of facts to support them both it took a
whole lot of internet digging to come up
with a conclusion the answer did this
Disney theory lies in the most magical
place on earth Disneyland
believe it or not that some dedicated
fans went to Disneyland to ask Belle
this very question and according to
multiple sources if you were to actually
ask Belle what book she was reading she
would let you know that the book was in
fact Sleeping Beauty there's also a
cottage in the Disneyland parks that
represents where Belle grew up in the
middle of this cottage you'll come
across the book Sleeping Beauty and it
said that Belle's mother used to read it
to her as a child so we guess that the
undeniable winner of this Disney theory
battle is in fact Sleeping Beauty be
sure to share this video with all of
your friends to find out if you were on
the same side of this did the theory
battle this is actually pretty cool
since you can definitely tell that Belle
has been inspired by Princess Aurora
from Sleeping Beauty in more ways than
just one
they are both known to be romantic
gentle and caring princesses who always
carry themselves with grace so did you
guess correctly let us know in the
comments section below and while you're
at it tell us which Disney movie you
prefer Aladdin or Sleeping Beauty and
that's all for today's video if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe to
the things and give this video a big
thumbs up we'll catch you next time
[Music]